sí
en esta elección retomaremos nuestro
simulador de pelotas de ping pong pero
esta vez desde un punto de vista
matemático y cuantitativo al final de la
lección habrás aprendido todo lo que
necesitas para programar tu propio
simulador de pelotas de ping pong y
mucho más
específicamente vamos a desarrollar
fórmulas matemáticas para hacer tres
cosas 1 describir cómo se mueven las
partículas con base en las leyes de la
física
2 controlar como condición a las
partículas con las paredes del
contenedor y entre ellas
3 crear un método para monitorear el
movimiento de las partículas en el
tiempo para empezar a entender cómo se
mueven las partículas dibujemos
distintos tipos de movimiento con un
movimiento nos referimos a cómo cambiará
la posición de las partículas conforme
avance el tiempo en nuestra lección
sobre animación nos dimos una idea
acerca de cómo se mueven las cosas en
esta lección animamos la pelota
dibujando la en distintos puntos en el
tiempo mediante el uso de los cuadros
señalados en la parte inferior de la
pantalla si dibujamos una pelota que se
mueve a la misma distancia entre cada
cuadro parece que se está deslizando a
lo largo de una superficie sin flexión
la velocidad no cambia es constante
significamos la posición de la pelota en
el tiempo obtenemos una línea recta aquí
el tiempo está expresado en el eje
horizontal y la distancia que la pelota
ha recorrido esta gráfica da en el eje
vertical
la pendiente de la recta nos indica qué
tan rápido se mueve una pendiente más
inclinada significa una mayor velocidad
la pendiente es el cambio en la posición
dividido entre el cambio en el tiempo
ahora bien qué sucede si queremos
graficar la velocidad de la pelota en el
tiempo si la velocidad de la pelota no
varía en absoluto obtenemos una gráfica
como ésta una línea recta horizontal un
reto más grande es animar la pelota de
manera que realmente parezca que se le
está aplicando la gravedad para hacerlo
tenemos que aumentar la distancia que la
pelota recorre en cada cuadro esto se
debe a que es necesario que la pelota
acelere mientras cae si gráfica mos la
posición de la pelota en el tiempo
obtenemos una curva esto es porque
estamos cambiando la pendiente de la
recta en cada cuadro ahora bien
significamos la velocidad de la pelota
en el tiempo obtenemos una recta que no
es horizontal eso nos indica que la
velocidad de la pelota ya no es
la pendiente de la recta nos indica qué
tan rápido está cambiando la velocidad
de la pelota y así como gráfica moss el
cambio en la posición para obtener la
velocidad de la pelota podemos graficar
el cambio en la velocidad para obtener
la aceleración de la pelota aquí tenemos
una gráfica de la aceleración de la
pelota respecto al tiempo observa que es
una línea recta lo cual significa que la
aceleración no cambia esto se debe a que
la aceleración de la gravedad es
constante en resumen la velocidad es la
pendiente de la posición de la pelota en
relación con la curva del tiempo de
manera similar la aceleración es la
pendiente de la velocidad en relación
con la curva del tiempo como se muestra
en las siguientes ecuaciones la
velocidad es igual al cambio en la
posición dividido entre el cambio en el
tiempo y la aceleración es igual al
cambio en la velocidad dividido entre el
cambio en el tiempo pero hagamos una
pausa aquí en el siguiente ejercicio
tendrás que pensar en cómo el movimiento
de los objetos cambia en el tiempo en
términos de posible
velocidad y aceleración